[Music]
you want a podcast
i got a smart cat you want a podcast i
got a smart cat
you want a podcast i got a smart cat you
wanna you wanna if you wanna
you
[Music]
kevin smith
[Music]
here we go kids welcome this podcast i'm
kevin smith so weird
to do it down the barrel of the camera
because i never really
shoot this but we're in rare breathing
space
uh today ladies and gentlemen a world
where
podcast giants can get together in one
room not via zoom
like the rest of the world doing it on
[ __ ] computers and [ __ ]
like real human beings we've gathered in
the real world one of us real scared
because one of us had real coveted six
weeks ago and [ __ ]
but uh i'm getting to sit down in uh
new jersey in the cradle of civilization
red bank
um with the gentleman of tell him steve
dave ladies and gentlemen so
of course the crossover between the two
audiences
is massive but for those who came in
late and are like who are these cats now
let me introduce you to the gentleman of
tell them steve dave to my left
walter flanagan ladies and gentlemen say
hi walt hello to my right
brian johnson ladies and gentlemen say
hi brett hello
master mimic brian johnson modern-day
rich little brian johnson
and uh over next to him of course uh is
the
the the firefighter in the group the
only true hero give it up for mr brian
quinn
thank you hello hello everyone hello
what
episode is t testy up to now
uh i think it's 479 will be the next one
going out
it's [ __ ] insane um you're nearing
the 500th show
yes it would have been a huge live show
but you know
covet we don't keep it that real yeah
well that's different from the huge live
show that you were going to do
for the 10th anniversary what was the
10th and then it became the 11th and
then we had to cancel it we just had to
shake
it because but if if there hadn't been a
covid
not only would you have had the 10th
anniversary show but you would also
probably be doing a live
500th episode show or am i wrong well i
think that would have been the 500th
episode we were trying to time it so
that it would have been the 500th
not last year but when we were going to
do the 11th we're like yeah we might be
able to get it in there right
but now it's it's not an issue
um so somberly put you know but now i
was really looking forward to the
show like normally i knew it yeah really
so [ __ ] broken
everything going good for this guy
married in love and [ __ ] he's like but
there's that thing that didn't happen
i'm great about being alive anyway
what is the let's talk about
um testy uh where where it started
versus
where it is right now you guys have been
doing it for over 10 years you passed
the 10 year anniversary
you're coming up on episode [ __ ] 500.
um we're in jane salembob's
secret stash the new version of the
secret stash which is a
65 versus 35 i always conflate the
numbers
uh the legendary stash from comic book
men
was at 35 broad street we are uh just
down the block
and in this space uh the testy cats
have what i kept calling it testy
theater while they were building it but
um
it really doesn't make sense because
people are like what we can go watch the
show and it's like oh i guess that's
i guess that's what a theater connotes
and or denotes and i was wrong
um i then i shifted to calling it the
testy museum because of the collection
of [ __ ]
but it is in fact the tesde town general
store or tesdo general store
tsd town general store um a store with
the historic kids uh
here at jane's selling bob secret stash
and also
now a production facility like uh
for those listening you can't see it for
those watching you might be able to
there's green screen to my left this is
a concept that blows
my [ __ ] mind not green screen that i
understand
is part of my world and [ __ ] but that
you two dudes particularly i can't even
lump quinn into this
but you two dude cause quinn going back
to like first meeting quinn quinn
was a a creature of hope that's what
they'll write on his gravestone
quinn a creature of hope he was a guy
who like was like
hey the world you know is it lies in
front of me
you two are the oldest [ __ ] young men
i've ever known in my life
who by the time we started hanging out
were both like it's all over
what was the point and [ __ ] like
really summed up life to what it was
and there was never any hint of
maybe we'll make a thing you know what
i'm saying
green screen means only one thing
maybe we'll make a thing and the reason
that and this ain't even maybe anymore
because
i don't i doubt that you guys would have
let a wall go green if you were like we
might get to green screen
it became something that was needed
because of how much
production you actually do yeah we do we
have done
quite a bit of green screen production
in the last three years when did that
start and why i mean i'm not questioning
like why would you do that but
i guess really it's more who in
in the three in the three of you who
first said
let's shoot something in front of green
screen that would probably be you
yeah are you [ __ ] me yeah because i
wanted to do a halloween episode and i
wanted to
have uh get him in a green suit
and we're gonna paint his face orange
and put a pumpkin make him look like a
pumpkin like a floating pumpkin and i
was like
how could we do that and i was talking
to tom mum from comic book men and he
goes well the easiest way to do it was
to is to get a green screen
and when he said green screen you're i'm
thinking like oh man it's gonna be like
tens of thousands of dollars
he goes no you can buy one for like 50
bucks
and you were like yeah so i was like but
then i just had to find someone
that could you know then film it and
then take out you know do all the
the editing part of it to make it look
like he's actually floating there
and i just put out the the
plea or to the the listener base i was
like hey man anybody
know anything about green screen and a
cat named
brian rupert from staten island yeah
great guy
you know he was like i can do it said
with the tone of a new jersey
from staten island meaning they're not
all a waste
you quinn and this boy they like to saw
me they throw me bones when they
every once in a while there's a real
kind
and when i saw how badass that halloween
episode looked on
we were like they put smoke behind us
they put backgrounds of
like a haunted forest that was it i was
like
and i knew that like there was there's
no longer a podcast we're a television
show
now this part of the story for anyone
who's been
like let's say they joined tesney five
years in
i think if they're if they're there from
day one they might kind of glean what
i'm talking about here but let's say you
joined from like
even say three years ago or somebody
jumped in and stuff even if they went
back and listened to the old catalog
i don't think most people would bat an
eyelash
at you guys making stuff and and being
in production [ __ ] like that
but knowing you as i thought i did or at
least as i did back in the day
um it's one of the most like that's the
part of this
all of this story that captures my
imagination makes me happiest that
you like the podcast is uh it doesn't
exist without you guys being makers
everybody making [ __ ] but the podcast is
like uh not heavy lifting because it
just requires us to sit around and say
should [ __ ] on them
once you get into the world of like this
has to
that becomes what they call like the
vision
like when people are like what's your
vision and [ __ ] i'm like i got none
here's the script follow that
that becomes visionary like it takes
somebody to be like
oh [ __ ] floating head should be easy
let's find somebody to do it
and then suddenly open that door and be
like oh i could do this
more and more oh yeah but we were lucky
enough to find really talented
people to help us along the way like
chuck and jack i think
what he's talking about though is
because i've seen what you're talking
about
happened play out like a car wreck in
slow motion but in reverse
yes yeah that's you know i'd be very
curious to hear your take on it
it's it's it the patreon was really
where i like there was always this
insane like surprising creativity coming
out of walt
that was like wow like this is fun and
then when the patreon started then it
was like
i would get text at like midnight about
like a pumpkin head
what about two pumpkin heads
like this this uh this creativity and
this passion just started coming at a
walt
that that uh it's almost hard to keep up
with and like started making me feel bad
about
my meager contributions
i used to be one-third of this and now i
show up i'm giving a script
and you don't know like you show up now
it's like and because nothing is done
like a real production
he he'll be like yeah just show up and
bring like a joker wig and i'll be like
all right and i'll come in and they'll
be like [ __ ] you that's how we do it in
hollywood
i'm like show up bring a joker we'll
figure it out right
so he's he's on it and like i'll walk in
and i'll just be for some reason every
time i walk into the stash
it's still going to be the three of us
and get them and maybe chuck like now
there's lights and there's cameras and
there's everything and i'm like oh we're
really working here this is fun
uh it's it's crazy it's closer it's now
looking more like your day job
yeah than it used to right yeah that's
one of the things like where like
like the patreon stuff definitely um
we try to be a little bit more uh like
in that vein
but i think that like i always lean on
that like you're coming from that every
day doing that ij stuff and doing it
with all the cameras and everything
so that's why i think that i i think tsd
should try to
be what you know for you guys what it
originally was which is this
very therapeutic not not not acting
and not like you know going off like you
know let's dress up in costumes and look
like dorks or whatever
you want to show up like something
happens when we show up and i'm like oh
i i really want to perform for you
it's almost like he's saying i'm like
all right well what are we doing all
right
i don't want to be the weak link here
it's like it's it's great and they like
guys like chuck they come in and they're
so professional you're like oh wow you
can't
you can't dial it in because it'll break
his heart when and when did chuck come
into it
chuck came into it we um we did a live
show
at the gramercy in new york new york i
don't know a couple years ago 2009
and 2016.
a lifetime ago uh
and um dexter oh yeah dexter contacted
chuck
and then okay and then chuck filmed the
live show and then
the footage was basically lost for
for over a year and then chuck contacted
me and i almost threw the email away
because it was such a long [ __ ] email
this [ __ ] guy
like you don't have time for this yeah
because this long email about this
practical joke you want to pull
and you wanted to send it to i don't
even remember i was just you know
as if he tells the tale he's like the
disgust like this man who changed our
lives
had a dumb idea and i hated it it was
almost i was almost hit and delete and
then he said i'm i'm the guy that
filmed um the grammar scene i had that
footage what do you want to do with it
hello new best friend
if he had if he hadn't put that in there
at the bottom yeah i i would have just
like just lost over that email and never
even the lesson here
kids is like lead with the pertinent
information
right in the first paragraph why i'm
important to you
um is is and
then i'm gonna get to you because i you
you have borne witness to more than all
of us
so your take is going to be very crucial
but is the
increase in like let's make stuff
directly related to the patreon
visa v we have an audience with
expectation
or oh we can just do literally anything
we want now i have to fill
i have to fill time i have to put assets
in seats so we need to make things
or so is it a is it fed by
responsibility or is it fed by
oh this would be [ __ ] fun i just want
to do this both
then then you and i are are one this is
like the proudest day of my life
because that's that's it that's the
[ __ ] key that's the secret
you've got a [ __ ] way to make a
living where you actually
would have done it anyway if you could
have done it inexpensively
and without putting anybody out the only
reason
you feel okay about putting people out
or whatever is because now
it's also a job there's money involved
but if there was no money involved
you would still be like it would
definitely still be audio
or audio because i feel like the like
the in the injection of
a budget yes allowed well allowed
me to be like all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna dress up everybody i guess the
cast of batman 66
and then we're going to get into star
wars costumes and then we're going to do
this because i had
i had i had money to play with so i was
like all right
a closet full of costumes as well that's
the key to this story i see downstairs
that the uh
the testy storeroom that's it's all
costumes it's like
it looks like something out of like the
[ __ ] first avenue playhouse backstage
yeah
yeah that's like that's how excited he
gets like he sent me a picture of that
room
and he goes we have our own wardrobe
that's like a child like you know what i
mean like it was a glitter yeah
like old school 1940s back you know like
an old like a wardrobe
or snl that's what they do at snl
there's a room full of [ __ ] clothing
where they're like go dress like a tiger
we have that now
it's funny we spent we literally these
guys don't know it but i literally spent
thousands on costumes
it's got to be convincing um we made the
a movie suit
for the movies pop-up joints and uh i
i i was like i want to get a you know
mascot suit and so somebody sent me to
the high school mascot
i should have said that because that
would have indicated cheaper but i said
in hollywood and they're like oh
use these people and it was the people
who make the suits for the masked singer
oh my god so you know the lady gave us a
price
and and she's like you know it was i
this is kind of a deal
and it was like 12 grand and i was like
you know
it's not even it's hard to say this but
a deal would be 10 grand and that's not
even a deal
so she got it down to 10 grand the
moment you spend 10 grand on a costume
give them an accounting that's when you
know you're in trouble somebody else
needs to be involved in the conversation
you have known
uh walter the longest brian johnson yeah
um 1978 is that it yeah
did you guys must have done in all your
shows have you you've
done the secret origin episode of like
the first conversation we had and all
that [ __ ]
uh we've talked about like things in
fifth grade that we remember like the
the wild ass picture that might that
walt drew for me and pam was like you
can't hang around with him anymore
because it was wild ass because it was
what it was an s with eyeballs that were
like you know
uncoordinated yeah looking in different
directions later it would be evil legs
remember that
yeah i remember evil like you have been
so you've known him the longest so
you've seen
walt flying in through the ages and now
you're very familiar with
walt flannigan uh entrepreneur
businessman
uh co-star [ __ ] all those things
it's pretty amazing yes if i'm [ __ ]
flabbergasted what was your perception
of me that like i
thought you were a loser i don't
understand this like
no you're a very like reserved kind of
guy like incredibly creative
brilliant i think but not like
the shows on patreon that you've made up
like that i love so much when you're
like
we're gonna do this thing called frank
five rewind where we look back at shows
that we like and we're just
to [ __ ] comment on them and i'm like
i can talk about tv shows
like thanks well that's my job yeah
that's my job and so many times i thank
the ants for like making it so
this is my job but really another person
to thank would be wrong
because without him it wouldn't be what
it is it definitely would not be
the around these parts uh there's a lot
of uh always walt hero worship because
as i've told walt many times as i said
many times in the real world i
i'm not and you guys aren't sitting here
having this conversation without walt
i'm not sitting here and having this
conversation
with you guys without wall i'm probably
still working
you know [ __ ] nine to five jobs if
i'm lucky and stuff like that meeting
walter flanagan
and i don't mean this to sound arrogant
by any stretch of the imagination but
follow me on this because i'll prove it
out
um was something that literally dented
the universe cracked it if you will
like made him and i meeting made such a
[ __ ] impact i had this effect on
girls when i was in high school
only boys look around you you're
surrounded by [ __ ] sausage
that's it there's a bunch of dudes going
he's the best
and a bunch of chicks going like no
like where was like i would have killed
for this adoration like in high school
the uh well you got it from me uh not in
high school but
post high school and stuff but if i
don't meet walt
i don't meet jay i don't meet you and
that means clerks doesn't really happen
because you're randall jay's jay um
i'm me but like that's not enough to
hang a [ __ ] motion picture on
so i could trace like everything back to
meeting walter and trying to
please walter the nut that you had to
crack yes like everything was against it
yes
you're not a friendly guy yes he's
absolutely right about that
it was earned work stand off i i'll i'll
i'll say i can point to people who will
who will say that i am a friendly guy
i agree it takes a little bit of time
yes yeah because i you know it's it's
tough
yes we've been together how long
tell him tell him i'm a good guy put the
girls on you uh you are
very slow to warm up to people there's i
thought about it like
in regards to is getting behind me he
was there at one point
yeah i thought about it in terms of get
him today when i was hanging out
we were doing the grand opening of the
stash this weekend that's why i'm here
in town and stuff
but as i was looking to get him and like
you were talking to get him at one point
i was like oh [ __ ] that's
had like an acolyte and i think i might
be the first because brian's a friend
what's that accolade i've heard acolyte
is somebody who's like i like what he
says i'm going to follow this priest
this whole week
so to me you were more like a shaman to
him you were an equal and a friend but i
come in
at our point in our relationship or when
our relationship begins
i'm like oh this [ __ ] guy's smart
like it's like what he says
where it's like he's [ __ ] i don't know
if i was like he's brilliant at that
point
i would come to know you were brilliant
but like so much of who i am and what i
went on to do
professionally is really predicated on
like two factors
uh if you were like what do you know
about kevin smith they're like [ __ ]
he likes comics and isn't he always
wearing that hockey jersey both of those
things literally came
from walt so mall rats
clerks is something that inarguably
changed the culture
and i could say that now with comfort
you know back in the day i'd be ashamed
to be like you can't say [ __ ] like that
over 25 years later it's definitely
changed the [ __ ] culture
clerks doesn't exist unless i meet walt
who then introduces me
to you who then introduces me to to jay
walt was there when we made clerks as
well at ground zero and this version of
walt flanagan
the one that like it has a green screen
the one that's like i bought all these
costumes
the one that like seems like an
alternate reality while planning it
i saw hints of that guy when we made
clerks
because there was a world where you know
day one everybody
is around to make the movie because like
this is new and fun and [ __ ]
by day three everyone dropped out
like people were just gone like you know
they were like ed stopped coming by day
three
it's just [ __ ] boring for people that
aren't
i mean we were i was gonna say people
aren't in on the action but we had such
a small group
everyone was in on the action but i
think you know ed was just kind of like
this is boring and he moved on and [ __ ]
walter was there every damn day
and the guy also least likely when i
went to the vancouver film school
walter like wrote me and was always like
more interested in like
that's for lack of a better description
it was almost like he was going
that's creative you're doing something
creative that's interesting
and it was never like that that was
always a part of my life that i kept
separate from you because i was like
i don't want to [ __ ] tell him that
i'm into making things because what if
he's like don't do that that's stupid
because i knew i would have used a
different word yes
back then a word that we're not allowed
to use anymore yes
back then it meant stupid as well
yes that was a question of sexuality
exactly but there was there was like uh
when i went away you would write when i
came home to make clerks you were there
for the whole thing
and then also acting in it was like real
revelation where you were like i'll do
that
because like you weren't a play kid in
high school like you weren't in the
theater or anything like that
but i saw glimpses of that cat when we
made
clerks because you were like this is
like for lack of a better description
you were like this is awesome
like i like this like making a movie
that's [ __ ] up let's do it
and it was never like a quinn type of
enthusiasm of like
gee this is great let's do this guys
that's how i said quinn forever
all right
it was more of a of like um
oh this like this is this is interesting
and like watching you now grow into
a maker and i know i like for some
reason i keep leaving out 10 years of
[ __ ] the podcast but
you know we all do podcasts that don't
require much that don't feel like being
a maker to me and i'm not taking
anything away from the audience
like [ __ ] you if you make a podcast
you're a maker but
like making something in terms of like
you show up at this time you wear this
[ __ ] costume you stand in front of
here you i need these lenses
that it's if i hadn't seen that dude on
the clerk's set
i would be like you were replaced by a
[ __ ] alien
really yes because even though you drew
and could draw insanely well
it was never you were never like i could
draw so i'm just going to make a comic
book
like that was the one thing that you
didn't have was that you didn't have
ambition an initiative to just be like
oh i could take it from here to here
like you could [ __ ] draw
but you were never like i'm gonna
[ __ ] draw the teenage mutant ninja
turtles
now you literally have like in your life
you have writ large with two [ __ ]
partners and [ __ ]
your own universe as i'm sitting in a
room that like is surrounded by
tchotchkes
of an adventure that has been going on
for 10 [ __ ] years that like
when people come into the stash that
don't know anything about jane salam bob
or the movies
i'm sure they look around and they're
like well this must be a thing to
somebody but i've never heard of this
[ __ ]
you will have the exact same effect on
people walking into this room
over here tell them to be like it's like
[ __ ] do you want to do you play magic
the gathering in here
you know what it hints at that it really
does when i look around the room i can
see it
but it's it's so weird and wonderful to
see
what has been built and and like this
but this
is the thing that captured my
imagination i was like i'm sorry did you
say they wanted a green wall
yeah well they do a lot of shooting i'm
like well i mean they can't do that that
much shooting can they like they do a
lot of green screen
and then i went and looked and i was
like jesus christ like they've become
the muppet show
it went from a podcast where like
literally i was there for the birth of
this podcast it was about like
one sad dude yeah and now it's about
funny costumes
yeah like the golden girls
zack snyder's justice league is now
streaming on
hbo max hey man it's me kevin smith and
i can tell you that i watched all four
hours of zack snyder's justice league in
one
sitting man from friday at one in the
morning to friday five in the morning
and i
love this beautiful film this is zack
snyder's definitive director's cut
of justice league fans demanded it and
hbo max
heard their calls packed full of dc
cameos and easter eggs but
it's a new film with new footage new
visual effects
and a total running time spilling just
over four hours split into six chapters
ben affleck henry cavill gal gadot
jason momoa ray fisher and ezra miller
reprise their roles
batman determined to ensure superman was
not
sacrificed in vain alliance forces would
die in a prince
and plans to recruit a team to protect
the world from an imminent threat
each of the recruits must face the
demons of their own past to transcend
that which has held them
back allowing them to come together and
finally form a league of heroes
now united batman wonder woman aquaman
cyborg and the flash
may be too late to save the planet from
steppenwolf
d'assad and dark side in their dreadful
intentions oh
i love the flick man you're you're now
going to be able to watch it see it
in all its glory on hbo max what are you
waiting for
haven't you waited long enough for the
damn snyder cut come on
dig in get some corn get something to
drink go to the bathroom before it
begins and sit down
and just luxuriate in zack snyder's
justice league
zack snyder's justice league is now
streaming on
hbo max
you are the you are at the epicenter of
the journey um
the reason that it all began was uh
to throw you a [ __ ] uh life preserver
something to cling to it has long
stopped sin
since that being that or am i wrong no i
would say
do you still use it like therapy all
that um maybe not as much as i once did
because the place isn't as deep and dark
but it's true but definitely let's talk
about that when you start so you're
almost 500 episodes in
right you may i mean you'll never be
you know done with your pain but you may
be through
like a lot of your [ __ ] dark [ __ ]
like number one you're [ __ ] happily
married
so that indicates you're through with a
lot of dark [ __ ] but
that entire time of 10 years of
essentially doing therapy on this
podcast
is probably why you're a lighter person
now
because there was a period when you were
you know pretty [ __ ] dark and stuff
like that
and not dark fun dark because there was
a period where you were you were always
dark
with a dark sense of humor but when the
sense of humor went away and the
darkness remained that's when it was
saturday
outside yes yeah well that was one of
the most shot i've talked about before
and i tell it all the time and i hope
whenever i tell him like jesus i hope
that he
doesn't care like that you're not like
shut the [ __ ] up
but like i tell the story of walter
reaching out and being like you should
call brian
and that is like a phone call that i've
never had from him
ever like [ __ ] and it would and we
don't talk on a regular basis so for him
to call it all
was kind of like uh-oh and i was like
why what's up and he said he doesn't
sound good lately man
and i called you and i was like what's
up big how are you
and you were like well i have one foot
on the stool and i was like
i didn't have that really i'm [ __ ] on
the floor
[Laughter]
my reaction was it's like oh jesus like
[ __ ] you're
you can't be that person because like i
think
like you're [ __ ] a god like if if
you're if you're if god is [ __ ] sad
and thinking about having one foot on
the stool where does that [ __ ]
leave me naturally your problems led
right to mine right where i was just
like what does this mean for me
so i you know i was i've said hey man
you should do podcasts like they love
you guys when you're on [ __ ] podcast
you sit around talking you would feel
[ __ ] you would hear what people say
about you you feel valued blah blah blah
so it started as like therapy for you
but no i'm not going to say therapy's
done because i guess i've never been to
therapy but that's a lifelong thing
but it would seem though that like
i for lack of a better description you
have unburdened yourself for a decade
yeah i'd say like when i was living in
la when i was running the the west coast
stash out there
i i saw a psychologist weekly
and it just really oh yeah dana i
remember dana you [ __ ] saw dana
yeah so let me tell you something kids
and we're not supposed to talk about
this because of
therapy or whatever the [ __ ] the rules
of it but at one point this dana person
was seeing brian johnson
scott moser jennifer schwabach and i was
like it's got to be me
i mean what are they all going in there
being like i hate them i just don't know
how to tell them
so you were seeing somebody and
i'm not saying like [ __ ] on that to
raise this but
talking to one person about your [ __ ]
versus talking to number two people
close friends and then the world as well
has it been more therapeutic than the
single conversation
absolutely certainly been more
profitable and more productive
and fun but that cost me money that's an
excellent point oh my god you're so
right
you used to pay for the [ __ ] therapy
now people pay you
to do therapy to listen to you talk
about your problems
it's nice i mean not nice that people
have problems that are similar to mine
but it is nice that they're like hey
i went through the same thing i'm going
through the same thing like it helped me
like the number of times i've heard that
the podcast has helped them
i don't really care about other people
that much but it does make you feel
vouched for that he's right yeah i don't
know very small list
but it's it's nice to know that like you
do have an effect and it's like that was
that would never happen in regular
therapy you know i would go and i would
be like hey you want to know what
happened in therapy today and so he'd be
like no not really i don't care
right whereas like maybe not everybody
cares about this particular issue that i
had this week but some people will be
able to relate
that's that's what i like just being and
that's like when we used to listen to
stern all the time
prior to him becoming a hampton oh
listen to you
getting judgey and [ __ ] thrown in some
[ __ ] shade on the side
hamptons howie to be fair credit where
credit's due
part of the reason we all podcast
probably the main reason we
well the main reason i do and part of
the reason i know you do and i
think it's probably in your dna but you
not so much because you were never a big
guy
i never listened to any radio stern is
in the dna of a lot of
things we do particularly of the podcast
stuff because that was
i remember listening to a dude being
like could you imagine like remember
the the thing that we would always say
to each other the dream job that brian
and i described as like oh my god that
would be it
was one time jackie martin martling
mentioned he made a thousand dollars a
week and this was like in the late 80s
early 90s
and me and him were like could you
imagine getting paid a [ __ ] thousand
dollars a week
to just sit around with your friends and
make fun of [ __ ] like oh my god that's
the dream you're literally [ __ ]
living that dream
doing far better than jackie markling in
the late 80s early 90s even now
um it is um it was two guys who are
sitting around a [ __ ] convenience
store just being like wouldn't that be
awesome and then it turns into it yeah
but i think
but that comes but but honestly like i
could trace that back to
walter the arrogance the hubris hubris
of being like
uh you know what i want to make a
[ __ ] movie and i think i can make an
interesting movie
like goes back to um
you going like i don't give a [ __ ] that
people don't read comic but some people
think comic books are stupid
like i'll never i tell it all the time
but you've [ __ ] literally said
you were like why because i was like
yeah but [ __ ] a lot of people make
fun of people that read comics they're
like who
i was like well i guess me is what i was
saying
but you were just like why would someone
make fun of me he's like [ __ ]
i read the watchmen they didn't i should
make fun of them and i was like my god
it's [ __ ] just a simple flip like
that and
the same thing got me to a place
eventually of like
even though you were never like kev you
should go out and [ __ ] tell stories
and blah blah blah
it was an ethos that i didn't have that
i adopted
like many things like you know i liked
comics when i was a kid in the super
friends and stuff but i gave it up in
high school because i was like i want to
get laid
and you were the guy that was like why
would i give this up
because don't look me
but you held down to comics all
throughout high school correct like you
kept reading and [ __ ] i did
oh yeah did you keep it on the down low
though yeah did you really
yeah in my in my hero's heart of my view
of you as in
in high school you put your feet up on a
teacher's desk and you're reading
your [ __ ] doc savage comics and [ __ ]
like this
the few parties i went to you remember
the friday night parties and high school
parties
it was real tough to just start talking
about comics you know
and try to impress people it was just
not happening but what do you mean like
eddie murphy like well
he's a good comic don't get me wrong but
a great comic is the watchman
um new walt would find a way
to market the comics at kegger hour
and make it part of the patreon yeah
everybody we're meeting down murray
speech
these members only how many levels do
you guys have does that make it sound
like scientology
when do they find out when they're
[ __ ] aliens
none of our ants are clear yet they're
still playing
they're still going clear
one two three four i think there's six
yeah six tears
um quinky you're uh for those who came
in late of course brian quinn here
is uh super [ __ ] famous for uh walter
mentioned it before
by hip initials but uh uh impractical
jokers i j
he said he was like i j and i was like
that's [ __ ] you could tell you must
talk about that on tell him steve dave
and nobody wants to say impractical
jokers anymore it's just become ij
it was it was joker's now it's just ij
this for me your role and tell him steve
dave
uh was always like oh brian gets to be
me like if i was here yeah i would have
[ __ ]
for sure [ __ ] sat in on this show
yeah
i think that's accurate but you uh
are the the essential third because
if one steps back from the show and
looks at it
it's kind of like a marriage counselor
who's been working for 10 years to keep
married people together do you see your
role
thusly yeah i always saw myself as kind
of like a pivot point
that could argue whatever both their
stances
like just kind of here in the middle and
stuff like that um
and reacting or just trying to rein it
in here and there i i actively try to
never drive the conversation
which is fun because these two are just
so great at it what's the difference
between this job and the other job well
other than the filthy lucra that true
true money you know the other job
it's it it's this is there's there's
never a time i don't want to do
uh tsd i always love coming down i
always have fun
you know the other one at times there's
an entire seasons where it's been a job
as opposed to me [ __ ] around my
friends this is always me [ __ ] around
with my friends
which is weird because that too is also
you [ __ ] around with your friends
i know you may be the luckiest person in
the world because your two jobs are
literally like oh
i have to go work with my [ __ ]
friends again and before that i worked
in a firehouse which was just a frat
house
it's like i've just been coasting along
on like this chummiest employee ever hey
man
i'm here to have fun guys um what is the
um
what's the most surprising thing to you
about the fact that you guys been doing
this a decade
actually that it's not surprising at all
i i i don't think this will stop for one
of us is dead
i think one of us dies then we do a big
wrap-up funeral episode and then that's
it
probably with a green screen
dead body reanimated you should really
put that in writing now
these guys should put together like a
testy pact where whoever dies
you agree to have your corpse animated
in a future video
originally the idea was walt wanted to
well we just all assumed i would die
first this was in the throes of my drugs
yeah i would have put money on that and
uh he wanted to stuff me and put me in
the stash with like a highlight reel
running on a tv screen brilliant i'd be
fantastic
mummify ripley's believe it or not
you're like is that a real body like oh
yeah yeah that's a former podcast
and the beard is still growing in
general oh that'd be awesome um
brian you also like uh in the midst
testy came before in practical jokes
yeah i can't ignore years
like three years before um but
impractical jokers bought a brewery
yeah uh well yeah i right i started a
beer company
um i didn't buy like i don't own the
brewery like i can't
give tours and stuff is that right so
you don't have a building
in my head you were like bart simpson
when he bought that building and yeah
he has an entire factory no because you
can wait and explain
you could like go to breweries and be
like hey man i gotta just rent your tank
it's like a ghost kitchen
where you can like run food out of
somebody else so it's like you could
either just to start a brewery is like
two million dollars
right and you know whereas to just rent
it is just the cost of a brew and a
little more so
so when did you get the idea to take
over
because it was a existing brand or not
well no it was a brand on stat
r h beer was a brand on staten island
from 1886
to 1950 and i had never heard about it
and then as i get older i started
getting more interested in staying out
in history and i started doing research
and i started
looking into stuff and i was like holy
[ __ ] this this brewery was
unbelievably successful it was it was
like a like a top shelf and then it just
got forgotten and i was like well that
doesn't seem right
so i i bought the trademark and and
hired uh
a brewery yeah yeah this is a woman
named amanda she's
[ __ ] unbelievable like she's she
takes like she sits down she's like well
what type of beer do you like and i
describe it to her and then she
comes back with like five or six
different uh test patches
and then i have the firehouse guys come
over and they drink it with me and we
give notes and it's like just a blast
it's a blast it's like i just wanted to
do something that was just fun like you
you know what i mean like just let's
just do this for fun so but the
difference between you and me is when i
want to do something for fun i'm like
let's put my face all over it my friends
yeah you wouldn't know if i tripped into
your [ __ ]
beer yes it's not like brian quinn brand
beer no i'm impractical beer
yeah like there's no
angle no hook what is that all about
that's me being a bad marketer i was
gonna say
yeah more comfortable like for me my
read on it was like
this cat's so [ __ ] cool he don't have
to stoop to buck and like buy my [ __ ]
like no i should stoop
yeah yeah smart money stupid yeah i'm
not stripping enough i got to stoop a
little bit more but it would have been
stupid
i have to like uh like when for the four
months we had before the pandemic shut
us down
i was going to bars and i was going in
bars and like buying the whole bar i saw
it on social media you were being a very
a very stupid yeah you were stupid
um but there was something about the
pandemic and we weren't really
you know i don't know it just felt like
a weird time to be like hey guys order
my beer you know what i mean
i don't know yeah
there you go there's an angle yeah i
wasn't in the mood for it and stuff like
that i i
so we you know i i do a radio show every
week for it
and uh i i do minimal but i i really
gotta do more i'm
i'm characters man [ __ ] like didn't
clooney make a billion dollars selling
booze
yeah that's actually what kara the woman
who runs the comedy she was like she was
like
this [ __ ] because we wanted a beer truck
and i was like nah just put the logo on
the side and she's like just put you on
the truck and i'm like i'm not doing
that
and she's like clooney if a truck drives
by it's his face drinking a tequila
she's like do it
and i didn't do it do it i didn't do it
i didn't do it i got to do it but i just
i don't know who meister told you to do
this yeah no just listen to the
brewmeister
the ceo of the company uh
so wait a second who who owns the
company i own the company
and what's the ceo ceo i don't know
that's just the title she wanted i think
so i just get you know whatever she runs
the company cara runs the
basically runs the company right on so
so all the administrative [ __ ] yeah
you're all the fun she's all the like
here's how you [ __ ]
to make this work yeah she she's been
working in breweries for decades uh
not that it's not that old but uh for a
long time and somewhere she's listening
[ __ ] you you know what i'm glad you
weren't on the side of the truck
so she she's um that was it exactly i
was like if you could do
the fun i'll do the fun stuff you do
everything else and she's got a mind for
it so i just let her make all the
decisions
did you meet her in a bar or something
like that no i've noticed since she was
seven uh
she was just my friend's uh little she
met at seven in a bar
yeah uh yeah so i don't know she's just
always impressed me as like a type a
beard does one need to be
like a beer liker or aficionado to be
involved in the beer business the two
ladies that run my company certainly
enjoy beer they drink it
a lot yeah every time i've seen her yeah
it seems like she likes beer they like
drinking a lot of beer
yeah but it's good it's a drunk co
[ __ ] jerk won't put his face on a
truck yeah [ __ ]
oh she put it on the side of a [ __ ]
building but not our truck
right outside the smodco offices in in
uh
california and los angeles giant [ __ ]
impractical
jokers [ __ ] side of a building oh
yeah i apologize too
every day we're like no it's very
i i'm rarely in the office but jordan
says like every day i see that it makes
me so [ __ ] happy she's like i can't
believe i know that person she's the
best
she wants she's just great yeah isn't it
weird though like you look at cue and
you think of such humble beginnings
yes and like well i think i'll be
getting out of the game
hostile beginnings yeah he walks into a
bookstore and [ __ ] tells off a poor
clerk
to impress the guy who made clerks mark
the iron that's vision
that is that's mission got him higher
that's for sure i was like i need that
young man
i need that kind of moxie it is that's
it's it's funny how red bank just over
here is because like this
this used to be uh a health i used to
get shots for
a wheatgrass shop yeah monica right here
so it's like i got
to be in here you know what i mean
that's right all these weird memories of
red banks
this is one of them scott monaco or
wheat grassers oh they went through like
two summers where that was it that's all
they wanted
dollar show the um what is the
what is the most fun thing that you
guys think you've done with tesdy
in the entire 10 years but it sounds
like most of the really fun stuff has
been happening in the last
three to five i found this stuff when we
went to the auction
like when we go to the flea market like
making hay yeah
[ __ ] episode three well we did we did
it three times
you've gone back
just out of curiosity why everybody else
likes making hay the best why can't i
but it's just that curiosity why only
three times when in 10 years how come
it's not like we went back once a year
for the making hey episode
i think it was just like it was special
occasions right yeah yeah it's just
there's not enough
people um it's charm you know look at
you
and that's cure that's called curating
like rather than just going like we're
gonna [ __ ]
you know uh [ __ ] all of these sheep you
know you're like we're gonna walk down
we're gonna [ __ ] one of those sheep
we're gonna walk down
that old adage fell apart in my mouth it
sounds way dirtier than i mentioned
um what about you um
man i really like the game show stuff
that we do i
i could i could pick like uh flan and
some was that elephants in the room oh
yeah i got like all the game show stuff
because it well the roasts
the roast was really roast was good a
good one because everybody was [ __ ]
vicious man everybody went for
everybody's throats it was hysterical it
was so funny yeah we put it out in 2016
we probably could not put it out in 2021
no yeah it was like a roast back of the
like back in the day on the one we
watched
look at dean martin yeah
wait a second who was that done for you
that was my first birthday
yeah but it was for the patreon audience
no it was patreon wasn't around then we
put it actually put it out on vinyl it's
uh it's on the bottom down there
that's one of the records it's one of
the records which record was it it was
the
the one with the cartoon like the john
great
yeah um i remember i got the first album
somebody i think you sent me a copy or
something like that and i put up a
picture like on twitter or something
like that and i instantly got
berated by a few ants who were like you
piece of [ __ ] i didn't even see it yo
you [ __ ] spoiled it
and i was like i guess that's how they
grow their fans over there
thought i was helping my bad
how many records have you made two two
uh 2.5 because we also released a little
mini
uh 45 of sunday jeff wrap
oh no the 45 this one yeah what
christmas one oh no
i
here at the grand opening uh we were
letting uh people who came for the grand
opening
signed the um fake steel shutters on the
fake quick stop in the back of the store
and a lot of the cats coming in were
putting up
their numbers and going like asking like
what's what's my number do you remember
oh i remember my number
and so i turned the wall and i was like
they're all putting up their [ __ ] uh
testing numbers and one goes like what's
that and i was like what do you mean
no i didn't i had not seen somebody it
was a card that's right
i knew what the numbers were he i was
like there's they had a card and he's
like i don't know what that is and stuff
but wait what you know what the numbers
are
i know what the numbers were yeah people
who joined up got a number uh
to the uh the motorcycle yeah but i
didn't realize that there was a
there was a card that they could print
out off the website i didn't realize i
i'd forgotten about that
when they and this was pre-patreon yeah
what were they joining
oh this was cute i mean cute like you
know covert mailing list
is that what it was what it sounds like
we're collecting data
uh i was watching uh um what was the
sons of anarchy
and uh getting into the whole motorcycle
culture and i was like wow we should
start like a a comic book themed
motorcycle
gang club and um so we were just like
[ __ ] it but but we anybody could join
we're like the rule was any all anybody
had to do was see a motorcycle
in their life and they could join them
and it it took off though it took like
midwest housewives show up like in
practical joker shows but like
the vests and stuff like that and a
patch in the back and i took the patch
to uh
me and you remember we met that hell's
angel guy in manhattan and i showed him
the patch
and the hell's angel essentially gave us
permission to do it
because we were like did you need the
permission oh yeah
wait wait what they could kill you and
not you know if you were seeing rocking
rocking that rocker
if you're in the wrong way territory
yeah this is yeah yeah this is real deep
[ __ ]
if you don't get i want to talk about
this yeah can we use code names
like if you're in the if you're in the
territory of a motorcycle club
and you don't basically just pay that
courtesy respect
then you you you can get started
courtesy of respect i'm just removing
your
sure it's the patch and then it says
like new york under under the bottom
that's called the rock the up the upside
down arc right and
what did you and so that is owned by the
hell's angels
no no that's a that's a motorcycle club
thing you got to earn now you got it
like you got to
probably kill somebody to get that rock
um well
back in the day i don't know if they
still got to kill these [ __ ] ass
they haven't changed
actually somebody had a sons of anarchy
cut on you know and
somebody made them take that off so you
don't know like how
yeah so somebody like in in some
fictional world or some
hyperbolic world or a hypothetical world
yeah
you could be wearing a four color
demon's patch no no you put new york the
thing is if you put the name of a town
underneath it
then you're claiming territory and if
you're on someone you guys
know that's what he i asked him about i
asked him to look at it he was like take
the rock take that off
there was a rocker and what did the
rocker say it was just gonna be whatever
town you were in
but so you hadn't designed it yet no
because it was just gonna be in the you
know
you know meaning london staten island
just some meaning like you would
would everyone get their own yeah you
would make whatever town you lived in if
you could just get it made up and that
was that was gonna be your town but we
but that would get someone killed yeah
because they're flaming territory
yeah they would could you at least
getting away for a fictional [ __ ]
biker gang predicated on comic books
could you imagine the
jump in our one numbers
lamb there's only one way to stay safe
you're joining but wait that was for the
four color demons yeah that was four
color demons
so the and that and people signed up and
what did they
they didn't buy something they just no
we because we we just got one free car
uh a communal like thing we weren't
looking you know we made the patches so
we were looking to make money
but um but it's grown up to a place i
mean it's a lot like your fans
but to a much lesser degree like they'll
have rallies where they'll meet at bars
and drink and stuff like that
and it's that thing where people are
like we wouldn't know each other if it
wasn't for this and we'd become friends
and things like that
we got married that's a sentiment i'm
very familiar with
the idea of like people i met a bunch of
people today who say the same thing i've
been hearing that [ __ ] for decades
i am inured to it not in a way where i'm
like i could care less about your
personal story it still touches me
but i've heard it so much in my life
that i
before the words come out i could be
like here comes and
what is it like for you guys
what was it like for you what was it
like to see somebody
[ __ ] quiver and cry or [ __ ] like
be like oh i don't i hate that i'm
certainly not like don't you love it
isn't it great don't you like when they
cower
when they come up to me and they don't
act that way
and there's no like there's no kind of
like weird awkwardness
and except on my part
but if i feel like i can feel that
awkwardness yeah it's really just like
it gives me anxiety
what if they all right what if they
don't have like convulsions or something
like that but
they're just cool but they but they hit
you with they go deep hard
where they're like you know no [ __ ]
lubricant anal they're just like
i almost tried to kill myself and your
voice is the voice that stopped me
do you get that uh i've gotten out i've
gotten i've gotten more emails like that
and i've actually you know deleted no no
[Laughter]
but i've gotten emails and i've kept up
correspondence with with a couple people
um who you know have to who have said
who broke into your iron heart
you've yeah who were he you know sent
the email and i responded
and then you know they'll come back a
couple months later and say things are
better now
and they'll mention something like on
the pod that can start a branch off to a
conversation that's not so heavy right
you know as like
something like they're dealing with such
uh problems and
so there's quite a few people though
that i that i've kept up with i never
even met them i don't know what they
look like
but you know that's that's pretty neat
one day they love writing you like i
feel brave enough to come into the store
and it's [ __ ]
drake somebody like super [ __ ] fame i
picked the wrong name
it's tom brady
um the uh what about you
what about me like when i hear that kind
of stuff yes have you had the moments
where somebody's like been like you
saved my life and here's why
definitely more in person than on email
like well because i go to conventions or
did go to conventions you've seen people
in the real world
and people yeah they're the two most
also to be fair for the record for those
that don't follow that closely
when it comes to live performance brian
has walter beat by a country mile
because walter hates live performance
yet brian will still go out and do live
performance outside
of tesde with things like space monkeys
with q
uh the e show you do with e on on uh
seriously whatever yeah compound yeah so
you you
interact with the public in a different
way with the public that has come in
specifically to see whereas walter for
years
because of the store has interacted with
the public some of whom are coming to
see him but not
all um but people who come to see you in
a public
setting they're like oh i'm there
because he said something funny this guy
particularly or that guy said something
funny and i'm there for and stuff
so that means it's a long way of saying
you encounter
more people who would like tell you that
in person versus like the emails that he
gets and stuff
yeah i get i get that he's like the man
in the high castle like how do we reach
him
like send him an email well walter he
says and i i
tend to agree that people are like hey
man i was gonna take my life but it was
not for you guys uh you know that would
have happened
and while it's like you know they would
have found something they may have found
something i disagree and that's probably
my
like wishful thinking and hubris because
i've heard it so many times i'm like i
did save that person's life i'm good
like mom said i was
but i i i do feel that that's true like
you know
i mean think about it they're i've never
been the very suicidal person in my life
but anytime i've ever been [ __ ] like
deeply blue or something like that
whatever's pulled me out of it has
become something to me that's like well
i mean look i went through a midlife
crisis that's why i like [ __ ] clung
to gretzky well out of nowhere i didn't
[ __ ] why
yes that was when i had a midlife crisis
i was like oh my god it came right after
[ __ ]
zach and mary make a porno and cop out
so it was back-to-back [ __ ]
hits where i was like and that was the
moment where i was like
oh i'm a no longer the golden boy
b no longer a boy c no longer [ __ ]
golden
and a lot of people think i'm a [ __ ]
joke and [ __ ] so
there was a tough transition period
there where i was like
do i i can't be that guy anymore because
i'm not the new kid
because now i'm [ __ ] established and
they've seen all my tricks and now they
don't [ __ ] like my tricks
like used to be i was like hey man
[ __ ] mall rats and you know critics
be like [ __ ] you but eventually the
audience came around
jane saw and bob strike back is not an
insanely well thought out movie in fact
having just read the first draft of it
recently
you know it's a miracle that that
[ __ ] movie got made at all but
generally speaking like
yeah by the time i got to zach and
murray
and cop out those were the two zach and
miri probably even more so than cop out
bruce willis just destroyed my spirit on
cop out and that was a different kind of
mid-life crisis
one where i was like do i even want to
work in this business anymore like
he's the top of the mountain and if this
is what the top of the mountain is
like i'd rather jump off the mountain
i'd rather [ __ ] work with jason muse
that's fun this guy's a [ __ ]
you know soulless [ __ ] animal
sorry that's probably maybe maybe a
little too intense to say
he just really dishonored the [ __ ]
he's the first person i ever worked with
that didn't want to be there
and i'm like even that far back huh it's
crazy yeah
crazy and still and you know it's years
later and i'm certainly over and i'm not
like i hate him still like i reached out
to him for jay and silent bob reboot he
passed of course but still i was like
hey
come play and [ __ ] he was like [ __ ] you
but um
that one broke my like
interest in the business like i after i
kind of walked away after that like
we made red state and i was like i'm
[ __ ] i mean i ain't doing this
anymore and that was the lingering
effects of bruce
that was part part of the midlife crisis
but zach and mary make a porno was like
that was the one that was supposed to be
huge like oh this movie's gonna make 100
million dollars and that's going to
change everything
and it wouldn't have changed anything i
would have kept making the same [ __ ]
movies i chose and stuff
but that one falling apart and [ __ ] i
made 30 million it made kevin smith
money
and it was just like that's it like
after all that work we had the guy from
knocked up
that [ __ ] cracked me and [ __ ] so
there have definitely been times
when gretzky came into that well yeah
widely enough into that void people
usually buy a sports car yeah 2k
or something yeah toupee well i've got
the hat so i don't need that
that's the trope i agree yeah i was just
saying like
anybody you looked at him and me and he
came up with both of those
he said he said it back to me he
parroted it that's why i looked at him
but like yeah why because
i mean i don't think i'm going through a
midlife crisis i think i love tom brady
more than you love gretzky
probably why well here's the question
well here's the thing is there anything
you could find out about tom brady that
would change the way how do i feel about
him
well i mean there's been some there's
been some some nasty news that have come
out you know he went for a ppp loan and
but that's not enough to make a true fan
like yourself be like
you got tipsy after the super bowl that
might be
that that might walt's got to buy us
against that so that i could see that
being the line that he could but you
know that's kind of nasty though they're
like
why would a guy need to apply for i mean
defending him but like you know what are
the chances he was the guy filling out
the paperwork
i was gonna say it was probably somebody
on his it's probably his camera
oh no i filled out the paperwork for
mine
i want that it was dream money i need
that yacht money
that was me i want to go sailing don't
you understand
there's no covert at sea 40 man but like
i said though like the
common things that people having in
midlife crisis
would not be a retired athlete because
although
yes you're absolutely right this is i
think because i've done a lot of
analysis
personal now i'm not not like sitting
down with a therapist but a lot of like
why did i go so hard on somebody that
like
isn't even in my line of work like it's
not like like all of a sudden i was like
scorsese don't you get it he's a [ __ ]
god of a filmmaker
i don't even play hockey and still like
i was drawn to that story
and i think and this is gonna sound
weird and i don't want to sound arrogant
but it's because of the similarities to
my own life i'm not the greatest at
anything i'm not
i've never hoisted [ __ ] that many
stanley cups but you're talking about a
dude who came from nowhere
whose parents were very [ __ ] sweet to
him and kind of encouraging
um and very encouraging in his case um
who went on the ride of a [ __ ]
lifetime but he went
way earlier so it started for him when
he was like literally 10 years old
you can listen to that dude doing
interviews as a 10 year old kid and he's
already got
like an angle like he's pre-possessed he
knows how to handle himself in front of
a [ __ ] microphone
so because he was retired when i
got into him i could look at the entire
career
there's no like because the numbers
meant nothing to me like you know
you know me as much as i like hockey
it's not like a long time
the stats what what cap captured my
imagination
and i think what has always eluded me as
regards sports
like why i've never had a real interest
in sports but why i do gravitate toward
hockey at all other than like [ __ ]
you introduce me to it
is there's always a story in hockey and
it's always a better story than most of
the other stories
like the in order to sell the game which
is a concept that you know it's a
cogent concept that they actually speak
about in in nhl in hockey in general
sell the game sell the game
because it's not like baseball it's not
like basketball it's not football it
doesn't pre-sell itself their audiences
for hockey are much smaller
so there's a bit of salesmanship
involved as well so not only are you
like i do a thing but i've got to tell
you how it's the best thing in the world
you could watch like oh my god have you
ever seen people skate
it's such a fast game and stuff like
that that appeals
or matches up with with me and as much
as like
i make a thing and i'm also responsible
for [ __ ]
selling the thing and gretzky did that
his entire career other than be like
fantastic at what he does and stuff
he sold the game so like
the way of life of the thing that he
leaned into
was equally as important to him not just
like [ __ ] stardom the other thing
that i really identified with
about was if you read gretzky's stories
in childhood and adulthood
edmonton stories king stories whatever
the [ __ ]
mark messier put it best i think he said
all you had to do was show up and do
your job and
magical things would [ __ ] happen so
gretzky was the kind of guy that could
easily make the shot
himself but instead he would just
shoot it to you so you could make the
[ __ ] shot and i think that's what i
dialed in on the most this was a guy who
was
and again i'm not saying i'm the
greatest just like him but this was a
guy who was exceptional at doing a thing
and rather than show off time and time
again which one could argue he did
because he holds the [ __ ] like
highest record not only in the nhl but
across
all sports his stats can't be touched by
any other [ __ ] athlete even tom brady
not even tom brady
in your heart perhaps
he doesn't have seven rings that's true
that's true
um but the fact that he would pass
and let teammates score is something
that like
you know i was like that's that's me
there's a scene in a
in uh um god what is it called it's an
old miramax movie
and christian bale's in it and it's glam
something
um [ __ ] i forget the name of it but it's
about the rise of
glam music and [ __ ] like that it was i
forgot the name escapes me the christian
bale plays a guy and at one point
there's a scene where
he's watching like david bowie
ziggy stardust or a david bowie ziggy
stardust like character on tv
and he's with his parents and he's
watching it with like silent awe
and then they cut to his internal
reaction like what he really wants to
[ __ ] say
and he turns around to his parents he's
like that's me that is me
like he identifies with this [ __ ]
person that's what i felt like
about gretzky wasn't the excellence who
were being exceptional
at something or incredibly gifted it was
the other things the adjuncts the bill
the guy who was humble enough to keep
selling the [ __ ] game even though he
really didn't have to
the guy who was like where's your stick
just put it down
bam and [ __ ] hit it off your stick so
you got the [ __ ]
point he gets the [ __ ] assist that
[ __ ] really appealed to me and the fact
that you can step back and look at his
entire life
work because it was done because he
retired and had a neat bow on it the
only problem was he retired with [ __ ]
the rangers but whatever
but like you can look at the entire
thing like a story as opposed to like
you know oh i watched this
game like you know how many gretzky
games i've ever watched in my life
not many because i didn't see them ever
live and i it wasn't a big enough fan to
go back and actually watch
gameplay i watched a lot of highlights
so but
yours is different yeah mine's because
he's active
and almighty i started out as i was
trolling the listeners of our podcast
because he because everybody hates them
so i was like initially i was just
like people that don't like this guy i
thought he's like the most beloved
[ __ ] quarterback of all time or
whatever
no people can't stand him because he is
the most because he wins the greatest
of all time so the same way people hated
gretzky because he's great but not
because he's an [ __ ] i don't know if
anybody's ever hated gretzky like i mean
he seems
like that aw shucks kind of like you
know like country kid who you know
represented his country won the gold
medals for them or yadda yadda
but there are people who just despise
tom brady because he's
[ __ ] a model he's got model looks
he's got a model
initially i was just being a troll i was
just being like i love tom brady i love
tom brady
and then as i started to watch and watch
i was just like he won me over i was
just like holy [ __ ]
that you know you you there's what do
you mean
like you were watching football yeah
just like watching it you've
seen him for years but suddenly through
this filter you're like
yeah because like his second act is more
impressive than his first act what does
he had a good beginning to his good
beginning and then kind of like
yeah then he kind of like he went
through a stretch rate and he wasn't
winning
super bowls and then he goes through the
second act
where everybody is like ready to like
write him off and like say he wasn't
he was all you know was all somebody
else is doing it wasn't his doing that
for the reasons that you know that that
team won
and he was just like you know he just
turns to the cameras like i'm gonna [ __ ]
you
and uh you suck my dick because i'm
gonna go i'm going to go to a different
team and i'm going to bring them to a
super bowl championship a team that was
like the
the lowest winning percentage in any
professional sport
and that was the reason that was the 10
buccaneers goes there
doesn't have a training camp tell us
that tells the organization
let me pick the players and i'll win a
super bowl
and then does it it's like a babe ruth
pointing to the
[ __ ] in the field and just hitting it
there but even more impressive babe's
just got to be like you know just got to
go
sit down because
there is no other athlete that can can
make the claims of what this guy has
done right i mean he's clown
climbed mount everest and if he can get
into if he could climb to the moon
he would i mean i mean the guy should
run for president after after he's done
playing football
such great conversation we're going to
put a pin in it right here
if you want to continue listening you're
going to head over to tell him steve
dave so
that's smodcast for this week but this
conversation is to be continued over on
tell them steve
or you can go watch if you're watching
this on my youtube channel you can watch
the next hour of this
at the patreon which again is
patreon.com
tell them steve dave that's my guest for
this week i'm kevin smith
ryan johnson brian quinn walt flanagan
have a week
[Music]
[Applause]
you